okay despite the fact that there was a
recent Target commercial featuring
almost all of the main cast from the OG
movie don't expect the new movie to
revolve around the likes of Lindsay
Lohan Rachel McAdams Amanda safreed and
Lacy chabar or to even have them period
because the new movie like the original
is focused on a group of high schoolers
and not to be rude but I don't think any
of those lovely actresses from the first
one can convincingly play like class of
so the main cast is a bunch of younger
upand cominging Stars more on them in a
minute as far as the original cast the
only ones who have been verified as
being in the new movie are Tina Fay and
Tim Meadows they play Miss norbury and
principal Duvall respectively